ladies and gentlemen the thrice
nominated Leonardo DiCaprio and Vice
President Al Gore
so mr. doar we've got a big crowd out
here tonight an even bigger one at home
is there is there anything you might
want to announce
I'm just here for the movies I'm just
here for the movies Leo and on this
occasion I'm here to thank all of the
talented people in this great industry
who've been part of the mission to
inspire a successful response to the
climate crisis and thank you Leo for
being such a great ally in this effort
thank you sir an American film industry
has always taken its obligations to
society very seriously and it's stepping
up once again to now tonight we're proud
to announce that for the first time in
the history of the Oscars this show is
officially gone green which means that
an environmentally intelligent practices
have been integrated fully into every
aspect of the planning and production of
these Academy Awards and you know what
it is not as hard as you might think
we have a long way to go but all of us
can do something in our own lives to
make a difference
check out WWE score com2 get ideas from
the Academy and the National Resources
Defense Council the NRDC about how you
can do your part and now though although
our time is almost up I just want to say
I'm very proud to be standing next to
such an inspirational leader in the
fight against global global warming you
are a true champion for the cause mr.
now are you sure are you positive that
all this hard work hasn't inspired you
to make any other kind of major major
announcement to the world here tonight
well I do appreciate that Leo and I'm
kind of surprised that the feelings
welling up here are actually been very
convincing and even though I honestly
had not planned on doing this I I guess
was a billion people watching it says
good a time as any so my fellow
Americans
I'm going to take this opportunity right
here and now to formally an hour
coming up more Ellen Cameron Diez Tom
Hanks and Helen Mirren plus a
one-time-only reunion performance from
Dreamgirls on the 79th annual Academy
Awards
you